i remember growing up he'd come around
every now and then
drop off some shoes buy his pizza
i need shoes man
i didn't need any sugars
matt james breaks down in tears after
confronting his dad about being
absent during his childhood i guard
myself
when tough conversations have come up i
ran from them and there's still
a lot of fear about what a long-term
commitment looks like
based on what i've seen in my family in
the past
and that's not healthy
it's not fair to me it's not fair to the
woman that i'm pursuing that's not
something i want to carry with me
on monday's episode of the bachelor
ahead of his fantasy suite dates with
michelle bree
and rachel matt had an emotional
conversation with his dad manny who
wasn't around for parts of matt's
childhood
harboring that negativity in my life
hasn't progressed in any of my
relationships
it's hindered my growth and for me to
move forward i need to address
those demons in my life and hopefully
today is the first step in doing that
the convo kicked off with manny telling
matt he wanted to celebrate his journey
but matt quickly revealed the real
reason he asked his dad to come
i want to have a family and i want to be
a dad i want to be a father what that
means to me
is showing up having tough conversations
being there when i needed you you
weren't there to have those
conversations
you started other families
that affected me
and i needed to know where your head was
at so that i don't make those same
mistakes
manny responded saying he didn't want
matt to make the same mistake
before sharing that his own dad was
killed when he was five
so he too didn't experience having a dad
and matt's mom patty left with the kids
for good reason who wants to be with
someone who's not going to be faithful
to him
i thank god that she had the courage
to stand up for herself and do something
because of the situation you put her in
matt explained that growing up without
him hardened his heart
adding that he doesn't want that feeling
to rear its head down the road in his
new relationship
i agree with you son i'll try it matt
i'll try
i'm sorry i hurt you son whatever i can
do to make it better i'll walk on it
because i want you to be happy to for
blessed your life and i want you to have
a relationship that's
healthy and not like what i went through
and matt said he wants his dad to be a
part of any relationship he's in
going forward you're my dad and
as much as i missed out on our
relationship
there's still a lot of life for both of
us to live and
i forgive you and while matt said this
was a good first step in his
relationship with his dad
former bachelorette rachel lindsay said
she felt
so disturbed after watching the
father-son conversation
on tv i felt it in my soul
and i had to speak out about it because
i am so disturbed
at what i just watched take place on the
bachelor stage
at the conversation between matt and his
father
the tv personality opened up on the
bachelor party podcast
and said that the scene lacked context
about who both matt
and his dad are what's the one thing we
know about his dad
that he wasn't around he wasn't around
that's it
that's all we know which if you know
anything about
stereotypes that are assigned to
particular races here
the black race um you know that
absentee fathers is a stereotype right
and
matt can't get to the next level until
he has
this conversation that's how this has
been presented to us
and she went on to question who approved
the conversation
making it into the episode if the
bachelor franchise has shown us
anything it's that they don't know how
to protect people of color they only
know how to exploit them
they only know how to mishandle
situations when they come to race
that is what they've shown us time and
time again this should have never been
aired for america to see as for matt
shortly before the conversation aired on
tv
he took to twitter to add some context
and perspective
quote too often we see dangerous
stereotypes and
negative depictions of black fathers in
media and they have consequences when
presented without context matt
added that he hopes people watch with
nuance care and also
an understanding that there are real
systemic issues at play
i'm so proud of myself for being
vulnerable and i'm so proud of my mother
i wouldn't be who i am without my dad
that's a fact